[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHARLES MCJILTON: Well, welcome.
Thank you very much
for coming today.
My name is Charles McJilton.
I am a social
entrepreneur, meaning
that I use business
principles and social market
issues, market issues to
deal with social issues.
I have represented four
different organizations here.
The one that you
might know the best
is the Rice Man, here,
Second Harvest Japan.
And so today I'm going to talk
to you about how to motivate,
how we use a concept here
called starting with why.
And basically there are three
parts to this presentation.
Right now, I'll tell you a
little bit more about myself
and what we do at
Second Harvest.
I'm going to show you the
whole video from Simon Sinek.
Has anybody seen his video?
You have.
OK, good, well, I hope you're
not bored to see it again.
And then I'm going to
show you how we apply it
at our organization.
Because we found it
to be very important.
So let's just get started.
I want to show you a
quick video of what we do.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - COLDPLAY, "CLOCKS"]
[END PLAYBACK]
CHARLES MCJILTON: So I
love this picture here,
because it illustrates
clearly what we do.
All that food, and all the
food you just saw in that video
there, would've been food that
would've been thrown away.
It's a cost to the
donor to throw it away.
And no company or person
wants to throw away food,
but they don't know
where to get it to.
We come in.
This is my staff,
my former staff,
pick it up and get
it out to people.
For them, it now has value.
But in that process
of picking it up,
what used to be a problem, a
cost, to that donor company,
is now of value.
They can say they're doing CSR.
They can say they're
engaged in the community.
And their staff feel
better about the company,
feel better about
their product, knowing
that it goes back into the
community to be used that day.
On the recipient side
of it, obviously they
can use the food to
nourish themselves.
But food is also a
tool for communication,
particularly in single
mother households,
where quite often, the mothers
are buying separate bentos
to feed the children.
Now with food, they
can cook together,
and it's a way to communicate.
So this really kind
of encapsulates
what we're trying
to do, make food
available to anybody in need.
But to kind of
understand our philosophy
and where it comes from,
and who we are today,
we need to go back 20 years ago.
So I've been now in
Japan for over 26 years.
And lived in a poor
section of Tokyo,
made a self-help center there.
But by the end of
1996, I had questions
about the viability of that.
And so I chose to go live
along the Sumida River.
And only intended to be
there for three months.
It's good to see you again.
And I ended up staying
there 15 months.
And it completely
changed my world view.
It's one thing to
think about poverty,
to think about hunger in the
comfort of one's own home,
or in academia.
It's quite different
than when you
have people living to the
left and right of you,
no more than two or three
meters away that struggle
with that issue each and
every day, and asking yourself
what should I do, what can I do,
what is my responsibility here.
And so, while I knew
these people many years
before I went to
go live down there,
it was quite a new experience
to come down there,
as we say, live in the gemba,
to live side by side together.
And it completely
changed my mind.
One day, I was looking over
the river just like this,
contemplating,
thinking about the men,
thinking about how people
thought about the men.
And some people think
that they're [JAPANESE],,
some people think that
they're [JAPANESE],,
why are they down there.
And I thought about my
own life, here in Japan,
up to that point.
And some people had
welcome me, some people
had not welcomed me.
I'd been discriminated against.
I thought about a
child in Calcutta.
A street child in Calcutta
who was hungry, and thought
about their situation,
how I felt when
I saw that child in Calcutta.
And I thought about
other social issues
in the world, climate change,
landmines in Afghanistan,
a number of these things.
And I came back to this phrase,
back, over and over again.
You may be familiar
with this phrase.
If you're not a part
of the solution,
you're part of the problem.
If you're not a part
of the solution,
you're part of the problem.
Over and over in my head
I'm thinking about this
as I'm looking at these men.
And I thought about the men.
They didn't feel that way.
They didn't feel anybody else
was responsible for them.
I thought about the
discrimination I faced.
And I didn't want anybody
to fight my own battles.
And I thought about
that child in Calcutta,
and I said, you know, I didn't
make that child poor, or any
of the social issues.
And I had an experience
that radically
changed my whole worldview.
And the insight that
I had was quite often
Westerner's sense of guilt
about the world's problems
is deeply rooted in
the exaggerated sense
of responsibility.
That people feel an over
sense of responsibility
for the world's problems.
And I shifted from feeling
responsible for the world's
problems to choosing to respond.
And I'll give you one
quick story here to clarify
how that plays out in my life.
Several years later,
I was in Seattle
with my brother, who is five
years younger, but probably two
times bigger than I am.
He's fairly muscular.
And a panhandler, a
guy begging for money,
had the courage to
come up to both of us,
and say, can you spare $5.
Typical response,
typical thing, right?
And without thinking,
without even pausing,
I turned to him with
no sarcasm in my voice.
I said, I'll pass
on that opportunity.
My brother-- he walked
away, looked at me
like this-- and my
brother looked at me like,
what the heck?
You'll pass on the opportunity?
I said, well, he gave
me an opportunity
to do something good, and I
just chose not to do that.
Now, if I had not had that
opportunity, that experience,
along the river, my
most likely response
would have been, well,
if I give him the money,
he's going to use
it for drinking,
or he doesn't look
like he needs it,
or some reason why I didn't
need to give them food.
But what I was really kind of
responding to there was I'm
not responsible for him.
Whereas, now, my
world view is I choose
to respond to what we do.
And we'll get into
that in a minute
here, when we talk about Second
Harvest, what our core why is.
That perspective that I had,
and that experience, and we
talked about it the other day,
at [INAUDIBLE],, is not unique.
Meaning that all of us have
these opportunities each
and every day, to step back
and reflect on our life.
What do day to day
experiences mean to us?
How do they reflect our
values, our worldview?
You don't need to live
along the Sumida River
to have an insight like that.
And I want to share
one more to you
that I stumbled across in 2013.
I was teaching at Sophia
University, NGO management,
and I stumbled
across this video.
I'm a leader.
So this really spoke
directly to me.
I said well, let me look at it.
And I said, oh my
god, this guy, we're
doing what he says we're
doing, what great companies do.
And since that time, we've
used it to refocus who we are,
how we approach things.
We saw this in last
year's campaign, almost
played out just exactly.
If you look at these two
different candidates, three
different candidates, we clearly
knew what Clinton wanted.
She won the presidency.
She had a campaign to do that,
talked badly about Trump, how
bad, how crazy he is.
Trump and Sanders, clearly,
we knew what their why was.
You can debate what
that exactly was.
But there's no doubt
among their supporters.
You knew exactly
what their why was.
And how they connected with
them was different ways,
Sanders very grassroots.
Trump, big rallies.
And the what, the idea
of becoming president
was almost an afterthought
for both of them.
You can look at online articles
and people consistently say,
we don't know why Clinton ran.
We know she wanted
to be the president.
But what was her why.
But these two people,
there's clearly--
and just as he was
talking about the airplane
inventors, the Wright brothers
and Samuel Pierpont Langley,
where is Clinton today?
If she was truly about her
why of changing the country,
it wouldn't matter if she
was a politician or not.
In our sense, in who we are as
an organization, our core why,
we don't define what we
do as helping people.
I'll say it one more time.
We do not define what
we do as helping people.
We just love food banking.
We just love giving away food.
Let me pause for
a second and ask
you, how many people were
surprised by that statement,
coming from a nonprofit.
How many?
Would you raise your hand?
Yeah, you're surprised, right?
But how many of you,
when you heard me say,
we just love food banking,
you felt some energy.
You felt, oh, yeah.
Because almost every
single time when
I have one on one discussion
with people and I say this,
I can see the
people's face change.
And it's not because they agree
with me about giving away food.
We'll talk about
that in a second.
But they can clearly identify
and connect with my core why.
You could see the
energy in my face.
That came from 20
years ago living along
the river, of choosing not to be
responsible, but to responding.
And one of my response
is to give away food.
How do we do that?
Trust and equality.
70% of Japanese distrust
nonprofits, 70%.
Less than 30% say that they
would trust a nonprofit here
in Japan.
We interface everyday with
the food industry, which
is probably the
strictest standards
in the world for food, and
the least risk adverse--
or the most risk risk adverse.
I think I always
get that mistaken.
2014, United
States, 3,400 people
died from food poisoning
or foodborne illnesses
in the United States.
320 million people, that's
not a lot of people.
Within the last five weeks
that number of people
have died from gunshot
wounds in the United States,
so we're not talking
about a lot of people.
But that same year,
2014, in Japan,
just three people,
just three people
died from foodborne illnesses.
Population of 120
million, consuming
nearly 89 million tons of food
or importing and using it.
That is not a lot.
To get that level, you have
to have NASA-like standards
for your food.
You do not trust anybody.
We say in Japan, if
the product, isn't
perfect, pristine
and presentable,
it doesn't get purchased.
That's the environment
we were operating in.
So we needed to create trust.
And here are the results.
10 years ago, we only
had 15 companies.
Now we have over 1,300.
Here's the interesting thing.
We don't do any solicitation.
We don't go around company
to company asking for food.
All 1,300 of those
companies approached us,
and sat down with us, and
offered us an agreement.
And all 1,300
companies, we have what
we call an equal
relationship with them.
Why is this so important for us?
It's not a matter of pride.
It's a matter of our approach.
If we go around company
to company and say
[SPEAKING JAPANESE],,
it unintentionally
puts the company above here.
It puts us down here.
So that when we pass out our
food, the people are down here
and we're up here.
We see food as a tool.
Companies have pumps and
patches, people over here
have bikes with flat tires.
If we can make that
lateral transfer,
that's all we want to be.
That's all we want to do.
That equality part is important.
What I will tell a company
that sits down in front of me,
I'll say we are not
interested in your food.
We want a trusting
relationship with you.
And we will match you pace
for pace to achieve that.
And now I'll go on
to give two examples.
Nichirei Foods in 2005
signed an agreement with us
after just three short weeks.
But Nichirei Foods is
traditionally a very, very
conservative company.
A different company,
which we never name,
but it's an actual fact, took
us five years, five years.
See, I don't want
the food from them,
what I want is for them to
get so excited about what
we do, they tell two
or three other people,
and here it is right here.
The what we do.
You could find that on our
home page or annual report.
Obviously, we provide
food to people
in a lot of different ways.
This is the end
result of what we do.
But when we talk about and
think about us, we go from why,
how, what in our discussions.
We used this this week
to work through a problem
that we've had for
many, many years.
And the problem focused
around the issue
of food loss and food waste.
Big topic in the media.
People talk about it all
the time, one third of food
is thrown away, 25% of
food is thrown away,
there's people hungry,
and stuff like this.
But we all, being in the field,
being experts in this area,
knew that a lot of
what was being said
was uninformed, uneducated,
and unsupported.
And so we would always criticize
these different activities,
the Zero Yen Kitchen,
[SPEAKING JAPANESE],, food loss,
all these.
And so my staff came to me and
says what are we going to do?
We can't run away
from this issue.
People are always
talking about it.
We've got to be part
of the conversation
even if we don't
believe in the movement.
In other words, there are 155
definitions for food loss.
Even countries that have
a single definition,
there's no way to measure
how much food loss is.
If you can't measure it, you
can't manage it, correct?
In the United
States, my country,
the government reports anywhere
from $33 million to $66 million
depending on what
definition they use.
So how are we going
to square this?
Well, we had good discussion.
And what we realized is
that we were focusing on
from the what side.
And so we came back said what is
our why, what is our core why.
We just love to give away food.
And so my staff and I each
shared a story that we own had.
He went to India at one time.
And so a child was
begging for food.
And instead of just
given the child money,
he said well, come,
and I'll feed you.
And he ended up feeding
10 of his family members
at a restaurant.
I shared my mind as a child
not having enough food,
not having lunches, and
what that meant to me.
And now having an opportunity
to give away food.
And then we thought
about, well, wait
a minute, these
people over here,
what's going on at
their core, their why.
Well, food is life.
Our fondest and deepest memories
are usually connected to food,
whether it be a wedding,
holidays, when we feel bad,
we get good food, maybe
our mothers might have
made us food that comforted us.
But food is such
an integral part
of us, and to see
it thrown away--
I love the Japanese
phrase of [JAPANESE]..
But we said, hey, you know what,
how about we focus on it here,
and then we talk about how we
can use that food as life--
this is the intersectionality--
and avoid all this.
And suddenly, we went
from being confrontational
each time about their
what to refocusing
on what is important
to us, and how can we
talk about food
loss and food waste
in a way that
reflects our values,
in a way that doesn't
alienate other people.
The last one, and it's
important with this discussion,
is that I can go
down and tell you
all the things that are wrong
with numbers, and facts,
and figures.
But that's all that is,
is facts and figures.
But I tell you a
story about myself
of not having enough
know food for breakfast,
or not being able to have lunch,
or my colleague can tell you
about him sharing dinner.
That's a memory.
That's an experience
that you can remember.
And that can motivate us.
How can we share more food?
Our vision is by
2020, that we want
to make food available
to 100,000 people.
Currently, there are
about 2.2 million people
that lack food security.
The vast majority of
these people are elderly.
The national population for
homeless is only around 6,200.
In Tokyo, it's less than 2,000.
The vast majority
of people in need
are not living on the streets.
They're living in
houses and apartments.
To get access to food, this
week, in New York City,
there are 1,100 different
locations to pick up food.
Even nearby Hong Kong has 160.
Tokyo, maybe six.
And I'm not referring to
church groups or other faith
based groups that provide
[JAPANESE] in the park.
I'm talking where you can
pick up a basket of food
to feed your family
for three or four days.
So we think of it like climbing
a mountain in some ways.
Our first step up that mountain
by 2020, is to reach 100,000.
Our big goal, the big
one, that we really
hope to get there some day is
that everybody has enough food.
And we want to think of
it like a public service,
a public asset.
I live way out in
the countryside.
It takes me about almost two
hours to get home every day.
I almost never use
the public library.
But if I felt the public
library wasn't there,
I would feel a public
asset was gone.
It's valuable to me.
I'm happy to pay taxes to
make sure that library's open.
Because it's not just a place
for people to read books,
but it's a place for
people to get knowledge,
for people to experience
a different world,
a place for people
to share information.
It's valuable to us.
And that's how we want to
see what a safety net is.
Is that even if you
don't use it today,
somebody in the community
might be able to use it.
And even that you may never
experienced food insecurity,
you know what it's like to
have everybody at the table.
And if I were to ask you to
take a step, just for a second,
and imagine that every
single child in Tokyo by 2020
could go to school on a full
stomach, how would that feel?
For me, personally,
makes me feel good.
Even though I don't
know all those children.
We have plenty of food.
So this is where your
opportunity to respond.
You know to partner with
us, use your talents
to help us to get food.
There's different
ways you can interact
with us to make that happen.
I know some of you are coming
out tomorrow, that's great.
And then also financially,
if you've ever
donated to us
financially, you may
want to know, what
impact does that have.
For every 1,000 yen you donate
to us, we can deliver 40 meals.
We arrive at that number
by taking our total costs,
overhead, everything,
and dividing it
by the number of meals that we
are able to deliver last year.
Let me give you the
last two quotes here.
I love these, one
by Martin Luther,
He plays on Hillel the
Elder, "If not us, then who?
If not now, then when?"
We reflect on that internally.
We don't want to assign
this work to other people,
or wait for other people
to take the action,
but we want to do something.
And we want to do whatever
we can do today, and not
wait until we retire,
or wait until something
changes in our life.
Even a small action today
could have a big impact.
The second one though
speaks more deeply to us
as an organization,
how we see the world.
It comes from Robert Kennedy.
"There are those who look
at the things the way
they are, and ask why.
I dream of things that
never were and ask why not?"
Instead of focusing on
why is there all this food
waste, why doesn't the
government do something.
We want to say,
what would it look
like if you and I partnered?
What would it look like if you
and I put our heads together?
What would that
banquet table look
like if we took some action
today to make something happen?
Focus on what the
possibilities are.
There's a lot more information
on our web site here.
It's bilingual.
And you can download
some information.
Thank you much for
your time today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]